okay I should try and get started okay so what we're going to do today is we're going to try and um do everything else that you need to know about word vectors and start to learn a teeny bit about new Nets and then we'll kind of get much further into sort of doing more with the math of new or Nets next week so this is the general plan um so I'm going to sort of uh sort of finish up from where I was last time with optimization Basics then look a little bit more about word to V and word
vectors and then some of the variants of word to v um and then I'm going to briefly consider alternatives sort of like what can you get from just counting words in different ways um then we're going to go on and talk a little bit about the evaluation of word vectors um the topic of word sensor that already came up a couple of times um last time when people were asking questions and then towards the end um start to introduce the idea of classification doing new classification and um what new
networks are about which is something that they'll then expand on more in the second week um before I get into that just notes on course um organization um so remember the first assignment is already out and it's it's due before class next Tuesday um so then um our python review session is going to be taught this Friday um 3:30 to 4:20 it's not going to be taught here it's going to be taught in gates bo1 the gates basement um and encourage everyone again to um come to office hours and help sessions they've
already started they're listed on the website um we're having these sort of um office our help sessions in classrooms with multiple Tas so um just turn up if you're on campus and you can be helped and if you are on campus we'd like you to just turn up that we do also have a zoom option for Stanford online students um finally I have office hours which I have not yet open but I will open sometime tonight um they're going to be on Monday afternoons now obviously given the number of people not everyone
can make it into my office hours and I'm going to do these by appointment so they're by 15minute appointments on kendley um but you know I'm very happy to talk to some people um and you know uh I put this little note at the end saying don't hog the slots um some people think it'd be a really good idea if they really work out how to sign up every week for an office hour session than me with me and that's sort of a little bit antisocial um so um think about that um okay so at the end
of last time I did a sort of bad job of trying to write on write on slides of working out the derivatives of word to be um and hopefully you could read it much more clearly in the the version that appears on the website where I was doing it at home more carefully um so that was saying that we had this lock function and our job was to work out its derivatives which would tell us which direction to go to walk downhill um and so I didn't really quite finish the loop here so you know we have some cost
function that we want to minimize and then we work out the gradients of that the gradient of that function to work out which direction is downhill and then the simplest algorithm is then that we that we work out the direction downhill we walk a little bit in that direction ction and then we repeat we work out the gradient at this point we walk downhill a little bit and we keep on going and we'll get to the minimum and with a sort of a one-dimensional function like this it's sort of very simple we're just
walking down hill but when we have a function of many many dimensions when we calculate the gradient at different points we might be starting to um walk in different directions and so that's why we need to do calculus and have gradients and so this gives us the basic algorithm of gradient descent um and so under the gradient descent algorithm um what we're doing is that we've got um our loss function J we're working out its gradient um and then we're taking a little bit of a
little multipli of the gradient so that Alpha is our step size or learning rate um and that's normally Alpha is a very small number number something like 10- 3 or 10-4 or maybe even 10- 5 so we're taking a really little bit of the gradient and then we're subtracting it from our parameters to get new parameters and as we do that we will walk downhill and the reason why we want to have a small learning rate is we don't want to walk too fast so if from here we worked out the gradient and said
it's in this direction and we just kept on walking we sort of might end up way over here or if we had a really big step size we might even end up at a worse Point than we started with so we want to take little steps to walk downhill and so that's the very basic gradient descent algorithm now the very basic gradient descent algorithm we never use what we actually use is the next thing up which is called stochastic gradient descent so the problem is for the basic gradient Cent algorithm we've worked out
um for an entire set of data um what the objective function is and what the um slope at the point of evaluation is and in general um we've got a lot of data in which we're Computing models so simply trying to calculate our objective function over all of our data for our model the training data for the model would take us a very very long time um and so that's very um very expensive to compute and so we'd wait a very long time before we make even a single step of gradient update um so for neural Nets
what you're always doing is using this variant that's called stochastic gradient descent and so for stochastic gradient descent what that means is we pick a very small subset of our data like maybe we pick 16 or 2 Data items and we pretend that's all of our data and we evaluate the function J based on that small subset and work out the gradient based on that small subset so it's a noisy inaccurate estimate of the gradient and we use that um to be the direction in which we walk um so that's
normally referred to also as having mini batches or mini batch gradient descent um and in theory working out the gradient based on this small subset um is an approximation but one of the interesting things in the way things have emerged in new network land is it turns out that new networks actually often work better when you throw some noise into the system that having this noise in the system gives you jiggle and moves things around and so actually stochastic gradient descent not only is way way faster but actually works better
as a system for optimization of neural networks okay so if you remember from last time um for um word de the idea was we started by just saying each word has a random um Vector representing it so we will literally sort of just get random small numbers and fill up the vectors with those random small numbers um there's an important point there which is you do have to initialize your vectors with random small numbers if you just leave the all the vectors as zero then nothing works um and that's because
if everything starts off the same you get these sort of false symmetries which means that you can't learn so you always do want to be initializing your vectors with random numbers and then we're going to go through each position in the Corpus using our estimates we're going to try try and predict the probability of words in the context as we talked about last time then we so that gives us an objective function from which we can then look at our errors look at our gradient um and update the vectors so
that they learn to predict surrounding words better and so the incredible thing is that we can do no more than that and we end up learning word vectors which actually capture quite a lot of the semantics the meaning and relationships between different words so you know when this was first um discovered um for these algorithms I mean it really feels like magic that you can just sort of do this math simple math over a lot of text um and actually learn about the meanings of words that it's sort of just sort of surprising
that something so simple could work but as time has gone on this same recipe has then been for all kinds of learning about um um the behavior of language from new networks um so let's just um go through a sense of how that is but before we do that so um let me just mention so for our word toac algorithms the only parameters of the model are these word vectors they're the outside word vectors and the center word vectors which we actually treat as disjoint as I mentioned last time and when we do the computations we're
considering the dot product between the various um possible outside words with our Center word and we using those to get a probability distribution over How likely the model thinks that different outside words were and then we're comparing that to the actual outside word in the context and that gives us our source of error so as such this is what's referred to in NLP as a bag of words model that it doesn't actually know about the structure of sentences and or even what's to the left and
what's to the right it's predicting exactly the same probabilities at each position to the left or right um but it's wanting to know about what kind of words appear in the context of the center word um so I just wanted to uh stop this for a minute and um let's see not that one um so give you some kind of a sense that this really um does work um so this is a little Jupiter notebook um that I've got um for this um okay and so this is using and here I'm using a package um gen Sim which we
don't continue to use after that really um but it's sort of one package that let you load and play with word vectors and the word vectors I'm going to use here are are glove word vectors and actually I'm going to um glove was a model we built at Stanford and I'm going to actually talk about it a little bit later um so strictly speaking um these aren't exactly word to ve word vectors but they behave in exactly the same way um and so okay so now it's loaded up by word vectors because the word vectors
are a big data file and so as we've discussed um for a word right that the representation of any word here is bread is just um a vector of real numbers right so um I'm using a 100 dimensional word vectors to keep things quicker um for my class demo so this is the word bread um and then I can say well what's the representation for croissant um and um this is croissant and we can sort of get a visual sense of oh they're at least a little bit similar right so the first components are both negative
the second components are both positive the third components are both negative and large the fourth components are both positive right they they seem like they're kind of similar vectors so that seems kind of hopeful because that means that it knows that bread and croissant are a bit um similar to each other um the this package has a nice simple function where rather than doing that by hand you can just ask it about all the word vectors and say which ones are most similar so I can ask it um what um words
in its vocabulary most similar to USA and in this model everything's been lowercased I should mention um and so if I do that it has Canada America U.S.A then United States Australia well those seem a fairly reasonable list of most similar words though you might think it's a little strange that Canada wins out over the USA with dots over it um um similarly I can ask if what's most similar to banana and I get coconut mango bananas potato pineapple fruit Etc again pretty sensible you know a little
bit of a bias to more tropical fruits or I can go to cron and ask what's most similar to cran the most similar things to cron isn't bread but it's things like Brios bagette fatcha um which sort of basically makes sense though here's pudding here um and I've got wait I'd already done oh sorry yeah I remember what this is right so with this most similar you've got a positive word vector and you're saying what other words are most similar in position to that that um there's something else you
can do which you can say is this is let me take the negative of that word vector and say what's most similar to the negative of it and you could possibly think a that might be useful to find antonyms or something like that I mean the truth is it isn't if you ask for the things that are most similar to the negative of the banana Vector um and in most other vectors it's the same you get off out these weirdo things things that you're not really sure if they're words at all or maybe they are in some other
language or some of them are names right like shichi is a Japanese name um but not very useful stuff don't that um they not don't really feel like a negative of banana but it turns out that from there we get this um powerful ability of um that was observed for word to ve which is that we could isolate semantic components um and then put them together in interesting ways so um looking at this picture what we could do is start with a positive Vector for King from the origin up the king then we could use the
negation to say subtract out the vector for man and then we could have another positive Vector of add on the um Vector for woman and then we can ask the model is if you're over here in the space um what is the nearest word to you over there and so um that's what this um next thing does right it's sort of says positive Vector for King negative for man also positive for Queen where does that get you to and that gets you to Queen yay um and so this was the most celebrated property that was discovered
with these word vectors that they weren't only good for meaning similarity but that they were good um for doing these kind of meaning components and these got referred to as analogies because that's you can think of them as a is to B as C is to what so it's sort of like um woman is to King no sorry um man is to King or King is to man as um I'm saying this the wrong way around man is to King as woman is to what um in the analogies and so here I've defined a little function that is now saying this
little function just automates that and we'll compute analogies um and so now I can ask it in just this analogy format um man is to King as woman is to queen and um that one was sort of the canonical example but you know you can actually sort of has have fun with this and I mean you know uh this is pretty oldfashioned stuff you know know I I feel like I'm maybe like now at this point an old guy talking about how much fun we used to have sitting around the radio listening to radio plays um because you know
basically no one uses this stuff anymore and there are much much better and fancier things like chat GPT but you know back in the day when I was younger um you know it was really stunning already just how this very simple model built on very simple data um could just have quite good semantic understanding and do quite good analogies so you can actually you know play with this quite a bit and have a bit of fun so you can do something like analogy Australia comma be France okay what people think the answer
will be close the answer gives us Champagne but that seems a pretty good answer um I could then put in Russia what what people think vodka yeah it'll see you can get back vodka you know this is actually works kind of interestingly um you know I could do a different one I can do the test something different I can do something like pencil is to sketching as camera is to photographing yeah that works quite well um so um we built this model in 2014 so it's a little bit out of date in politics so you know well we we can't do
the last decade of politics which is maybe unfortunate but you know we could try out older politics questions so we could try um Obama is to Clinton as Reagan is to if you remember your Us world history class any guesses what it's going to say there's a bush one any other ideas some people have different opinions of Bill Clinton any uh um what it answers is Nixon which I think is actually kind of fair um but um you can also get it to do some just sort of language syntactic facts so you can do something like tallest to
tallest as long oops as long is to this one's easy um yeah so you know with this simp simple method of learning with this simple bag of words model it's enough to learn a lot about the semantics of words and you know stuff that's beyond conventional semantics right you know like our examples with Australia De Beer as Russia as to vodka I mean that sort of cultural World Knowledge which goes a little bit beyond um what people normally think of as sort of word meaning semantics but it's also in there
yes if you perhaps subract the distance from let's say like man and King does that also capture a concept of relationship between two words like would that give you back like ruler like something like that we taking the like the difference between two vectors does capture some right the distance between man so so Man compared to King should be a ruler concept but isn't that what I'm using CU then I'm taking that I'm taking the distance between man and King is what I'm adding on to woman to
get the queen right right yeah so I can depending on if you think of these words depending on which thing you think of as the analogy you can think of it you've both got um a a vector a difference Vector between words that gives you a gender analogy and one that gives you a ruler analogy yeah absolutely any other questions yeah um in the watch ve umm we get two vectors like for each one a u and a v but here you only have one vector so how do you go from two to one yeah good question I mean the commonest
way in practice was you just average the two of them and and and really you sort of find out that they um end up very close you know um because if you think of it since you're going along every position of the text you're both going to be the case where if the text is sort of you know the octopus has legs you know you're going to have octopus in the center with legs in the context and a couple of time steps later it's going to be legs in the center with octavus in the context so
you know although they vary a bit for all the regions of the neuron Nets very basically they end up very similar and people normally just average them yeah can you this process so use this uh the answer of one to then be placed into the analogy function of the another and see how far away you can go before it SS break down I think you can um so you what wait you're wanting to how far away how distant of a relation between two words can you do before it starts providing incorrect relationship
between but are you wanting to sort of make two steps from somewhere or yeah St many St go away froming so it doesn't always work I mean there are so examples that are fail um I'm sort of shy to try that now because I don't have a predefined function that did it and that might take me um too long but you could play with it at home and see how it works for you curious is a clarification why is it that we use two separate sets of vectors for word uh is it just to get more parameters or is there um I'll get back
to that maybe I should go on at this point um let me move on and kind of just get through some more details of the word Tove algorithm um so um just a technical point on this class so you don't make any big mistakes and waste your weekend I mean for most instances of 224n we've actually had people Implement from scratch word to VC as assignment to um but you know for this quarter doing it in Spring quarter as you probably know Spring quarter is actually a little shorter than the other two quarters um we decided to skip
having people Implement word to VC um so don't look at the old assignment to that says Implement word to V or else you'll be misspending your time wait for the newer assignment to to come out um but you know despite that let me just sort of um say a little bit more about some of the details right yeah so why two vectors um so the two vectors is it just makes the math a little bit easy so if you think about the math right if you have the same vectors for the center word and for the outside words well for
whatever the the center word is let's say it's octopus that when you're going through the trying out every possible context word for the normalization at some point you'll hit octopus again and so at that point you'll have a quadratic term right you'll have the x squared of the octopus vector and that kind of messes up I mean you're clever people you could work out the math of it but it makes the math more of a mess right CU every other term it's something different and it's just like a X and
then at one position you've got an x s um so it just makes the math Messier and so they kept it really simple by just having them be disjoint vectors but it it doesn't make it better I mean it actually turns out it works a fraction better if you do it right um but in practice people have usually just estimated them separately and then average them at the end um there if if you actually look at the paper here's m of it out you can find it 2013 paper um there's actually sort of a family of
methods that they describe um so they described two methods one of which um was that you have an inside word that's predicting the words around it and then the other one tried to predict the center word from all the words in the context which was called continuous bag of words in their paper um the one that I've described is Skip gram which is simpler and works just great um but then the other part of it is um for working out um what loss function to be used for training and what I've um presented so
far um is naive soft Max where we just consider every possible choice of a context word and just run all the math um you know that's totally doable and with our modern super fast computers it's not even that unreasonable to do we do things like this all the time but at least at the time that they um wrote their paper this seemed kind of expensive and they considered other Alternatives um like a hierarchical softmax which I'm not going to explain right now but I do just want to explain
negative sampling okay so this is just to sort of see a bit of a different way of doing things so for what we did last time we had this sort of straightforward soft Max equation and so in the denominator you're summing over every word in the vocabulary um and so if you might have 400,000 words in your vocabulary a lot of words in human languages you know that's kind of a a big sum especially when for each element of the sum you're taking a DOT product between 100 dimensional or 300 dimensional vectors
and then exponentiating it right a lot of math going on somewhere in there um so maybe we could short circuit that and so the idea of the negative sampling was to say well rather than evaluating it for every single possible word maybe we could just sort of train some simple logistic regressions where they're going to say you should like the true word that's in the context and if we randomly pick a few other words you shouldn't like them very much um and that's skip gram negative sampling so that's what
this looks like as an equation um so we've got our Center word and our actual context word and we're um saying well let's work out the term for the actual Center word we'd like this to be um high probability um so since we're minimizing we're going to negate that and have it go down and then we're going to sample some other words and we'd like this to be the opposite um but the the other thing that we've changed here is now we're not using the soft Max anymore
we're using this Sigma which stands for the logistic function which is often called the sigmoid um sigmoid just means s-shaped and but you know you could actually have an Infinity of s-shaped functions and the one that we actually use is the logistic function so the logistic function has this form and and Maps um from any real number to a probability between zero and one um so what we're wanting to say at that point is for the real outside world we're hoping that this dot product is large so
its probability is near one um and so that will then sort of help with the minimization and for the other words we'd like their probability to be small um so we what like them to appear sort of over here um and that's what this is calculating but as written it's sort of sticking the minus sign on the inside there which works because of the this is symmetric right so you're wanting to be over here which means that if you negate it you'll be on this side which will be large okay um
and so then the final bit of this which is the asterisk is so we're going to pick a few words you know it might only be five or 10 that are our negative samples um but for picking those words what works well is not just to sort of pick sort of randomly uniformly from all the 400,000 words in our vocab what you basically want to do is sort of be paying attention to how common the words are something like that is a really common word and so we refer to that as the unigram distribution that means
you're s just taking individual words independently how commonly they are so about 10% of the time you'd be choosing the um but so that's sort of roughly what you want to do for sampling but people have found that you can actually do even a bit better than that so the standard thing that they presented for word DEC is you're taking the unigram probability of the word and raising it to the power of 34 uh what does that end up doing question for the audience if I take probabilities and raise them to the
three quarters some less frequent words just become sing more correct yeah so the raising to the 34s means that you're sort of somewhat upping the probability of the less frequent words so you're sort of in between you know between having every word uniform and exactly using their relative frequencies in the text you're sort of moving a little bit in the direction of uniform and so you get better results by going somewhat in the distance of sampling more uniformly but you don't want to go all the way
there which should correspond to I guess putting um a zero in there rather than three quarters okay um yeah okay uh let's see I had a side here but Time Rushes along so let's not bother with this side it's not that important um okay so that's um the word to VC algorithm that we've seen all of um in its different forms um a reasonable uh wonder that you have at this point is you know this seems a kind of a weird way of doing what we're wanting to do right the idea is look we have this text we have
words and we have words in the context of words it sort of seems like an obvious thing to do would be to say let's just count some statistics we have words and there are other words that occur in their context so let's just see how often the word word swim occurs next to octopus and how often the word fish occurs next to octopus let's get some counts um and see how often words occur in the context of other words and maybe we could use that um to calculate some form of word vectors um and so that's
something that people have already also considered so if we use the same kind of idea of a context window we could just make a matrix of how often words occur in the context of other words and so you know here's a baby example my Corpus is I like deep learning I like NLP I enjoy flying um and my context window I'm using is just one word to the left and the right and then I can make this kind of um co-occurrence count Matrix um where I'm putting in the counts of different words in every context and you
know because my Corpus is so small um every thing in the Matrix is a zero or one except for right here where I've got the twos because I have I like twice right but in principle I've got a matrix of counts for all the different counts here um so maybe you know this gives this gives me a word Vector right you know here's a word Vector for deep um is this long Vector here and you know I could just say that is my word vector and indeed sometimes people have done that but they're kind of of ungainly
word vectors because if we have 400,000 words in our vocabulary the size of this Matrix is 400,000 by 400,000 which is a lot worse than our word ve word vectors because if we're making them only 100 dimensional um we've only got 400,000 by 100 which is still a big number but it's a lot smaller than 400,000 time 400,000 so that's inconvenient so when people have started with um these kind of cooccurrence Matrix um the general thing that people have done is to say well somehow we want to reduce the
dimensionality of that Matrix so that we have a smaller Matrix to deal with um and so then how can we reduce the dimensionality of the Matrix and at this point if you remember your linear algebra and stuff like that you should be thinking of things like PCA and particular if you want it to work for any Matrix of any shape there's the um singular value decomposition so there the classic singular value decomposition for any Matrix you can rewrite it as a product of three matrices a u and a v which are both
orthonormal um which means that um you get these um independent um vectors um they orthog to each other um and then in the middle we have the singular vectors which are ordered in size is the most important singular vector and these are sort of waiting terms on the different number of uh the different dimensions and so this is sort of the full SVD decomposition um but you know part of it is a relevant because if I've got this picture you know nothing is happening in the part that's sort of shown in yellow
there um but if you want you know at the moment you know this is just an a a good a full decomposition but if we wanting to have sort of smaller low dimensional vectors well the next trick we pull is we say well we know where the smallest singular vectors are so we could just set them to zero and if we did that then more of this goes away and we end up with two-dimensional representation of our words and so that gives us another way of um forming low-dimensional word representations um and this had actually
been explored before modern new word vectors and using algorithms such as latent semantic analysis um and it is sort of half worked but it never worked very well but you know some people especially in psychology had kept on working on it um and among other people in the early 2000s there was this grad student um Doug roie who kept on working on it and he came up with an algorithm um that he called Kohl's and you know he he had known as other people before him had known that just sort of doing an SVD
on Raw counts didn't seem to give you word vectors that worked very well um but he had some ideas to do better than that um so one thing that helps a lot is if you log the frequencies so you can put log frequencies in the cells um but then um he sort of used some other ideas some of which were also picked up in word to V one of which is ramping the windows so that you count closer words more than further away words um he used piercon correlations instead of counts Etc but he ended up coming up with a low dial
version of Word vectors that are sort of ultimately still based on an SVD um and he got out these word vectors and you know interestingly sort of no one really noticed at the time but Doug roie in his dissertation effectively discovered this same property of having linear semantic components so look here we go here's one of so this is actually you know picture from his dissertation and look here you know we've got this meaning component which is doer of an event and he's essentially shown with the way he's
processed his word vectors that the do of an event is a linear meaning component that you can use to move between a verb and the doer of the verb kind of cool but he didn't become famous because no one was paying attention to what he had come up with so that so once word DEC um became popular that was something that I was kind of interested in and so um working together with a postto Jeffrey Pennington um we thought that you know you there was interest in this sort of space of having doing things with matrices of counts and how
do you then get them to work well as word vectors in the same way that word de V worked well as word vectors and so that's what led um into the glove algorithm that was what I was actually showing you and so um what we wanted was to say look we want a model in which um linear components sort of adding or subtracting a vector in a vector space correspond to a meaning difference how can we do that um and Jeffrey um did good thinking and uh math and um thought about that for a bit and his solution
was to say well if we think of um that ratios of cooccurrence probabilities can encode meaning components so if we can make a ratio of cooccurrence probabilities into something linear in the vector space will get the kind of result that word DEC or Doug Ro got um so what does that mean well so if you start thinking of words occurring in the context of I ice you might think that sort of solid and water are likely to K near ice and gas or a random word like random aren't likely to occur near ice
but and similar for steam you'd expect um that you know gas and water are likely to occur near steam but probably not solid or random and well if you're just looking at one of these you don't really get meaning components because you get something that's large here or large here but if you then look at the ratio of two of these cooccurrence probabilities then what you get out is that for solid it's going to be large and small is going to be um and for gas it's going to be small and so you're
getting a direction in the space which will correspond to the um solid liquid gas dimension of physics um whereas for the other words it will be about one um this is just uh uh the wave your hands this was the conception of the idea but if you actually do the counts this actually works out so using real data this is what you get for cooccurrence and indeed you kind of get these sort of factors of 10 um in both of these directions of these two and the numbers are over there are approximately one um
so um Jeffrey's idea was well we going to start with a cooccurrence count Matrix and we want to make this turn into a linear component and well how do you do that well first of all it sort of makes sense immediately that you should be putting a login right because once you put a log in um this ratio will be being turned into something that's subtracted um and so simply all you have to do is have a log by linear model where the um dotproduct of two word vectors models this conditional probability and then the difference
between two vectors will be corresponding to this log of the ratio of their cooccurrence probabilities um so that was basically the glove model um so you're wanting to you know model this dot product um such that it's being close to the log of the cooccur Cur probability but you sort of do a little bit of extra work to have some biased terms and and some frequency thresholds which aren't very important um so I'm going to skip past them but I think that basic intuition as to what's
the important thing to get linear meaning components is a good one to know about okay is everyone good today cool yes all right noticed the the original X Matrix you show was like 3x 5 or something shouldn't It Be Square so yeah I mean if you're doing sorry yeah I maybe should have just shown you a square one if you're just doing vocabulary to vocabulary yes it should be square um but there was a bit in the slides that I didn't mention that there was another way you could do it where
you did it words versus documents and then it would be non Square um but yeah you're right so let we can just just um consider the square case Okay um so you know hey I showed you that demo of the glove vectors and they work great didn't they um so you know these are good vectors um but in general in NLP we'd like to have things that we can evaluate and know whether things are really good um and so everywhere through the course we're going to want to evaluate things and work out how good they are and what's
better and what's worse um and so one of the fundamental Notions of evaluation that will come up again and again is intrinsic and extrinsic evaluations so an intrinsic evaluation is where you are doing a very specific internal subtask and you just try and score whether it's good or bad so normally intrinsic evaluations are fast to compute help you understand the component you're building but they are sort of distant from your Downstream task and improving the numbers internally may or may not help
you and that's um the contrast with an extrinsic evaluation um which is that you've got some real task you want to do question answering or document summarization or machine translation um and you want to know whether some clever bit of um internal modeling will help you on that task so then you have to sort of run an entire system and work out Downstream accuracies um and find out whether it actually helps you at the end of the day um but that often means it's kind of you know indirect so harder to see exactly
what's happening in your task um so for something like word vectors you know if we just sort of measure are they modeling word similarity well that's an intrinsic evaluation but you know we'd probably like to know whether they model word similarity well for some Downstream task which might be um doing web search right we'd like um when you say you know cell phone or mobile phone that it comes out at about the same um so that would then be web search might be our extrinsic evaluation okay so for word factors um
two two intrinsic evaluations the ones we've already seen so there's the word Vector analogies um you know I cheated when I showed you the glove demo I only showed you ones that work but if you play for it yourself you can find some that don't work um so what we can do is sort of have a set of um word analogies and find out which ones work now you know in general glove does work you know here's a set of word vectors um showing you um the sort of um female distinction it's kind of good
and linear but in general for different ones it's going to work and it's not work and you're going to be able to score what percentage of the time it works um or we can do um word similarity How We Do word similarity is we actually use human judgments of similarity so um psychologists ask undergrads and they say here is the word plane and car how similar are they on a scale of 1 to 10 or 0 to 10 maybe actually I think it's 0 to 10 here on a scale of 0 to 10 and the person says seven and then they ask
another person um and uh they average what the undergrads say and they come out with these numbers so you know Tiger Tiger gets 10 book and paper got a an average of 7.46 um plane and car got 5.77 um stock and phone got 1.62 and stock and jaguar got 0.92 um noisy process but you roughly get to see how similar people think words are and so then we ask our models to also score how similar they think words are and then we get models of how well the scores are correlated um between um human judgments and our
models judgments um and so here are sort of a big table of numbers that we um don't need to go through all of but you know it sort of shows that a plain SVD Works terribly simply doing SVD over log counts already starts to work reasonably um and then you know here's um the two word DEC algorithms sibo and Skip gram and here are numbers from our glove vectors and so you get these kind of scores that you can then score different models as to how good they are and well then you can ALS oh sorry yeah
um that's the only thing I have there but you know what can you do for Downstream evaluation well then you want to um pick some Downstream task and so a simple Downstream task that's been used a lot um in NLP is what's called named entity recognition and so that's recognizing names of things and what type they are um so if the sentence is Chris Manning lives in poo Alto you want to say Chris and Manning that's the name of a person and poo and outto that's the name of a place um so that can be the
task and well that's the kind of task which you might think word vectors would help you with um and it's um indeed the case right so he what's label was discreet was a baseline symbolic um probabilistic um name entity recognition task and by putting word vectors into it you can make them the numbers go up so these numbers for glav are higher than the ones on the first line and so I'm getting substantial improvements from adding word vectors to my system yay um okay um I'll pile ahead into the next thing
this next one I think is interesting we should spend a minute on and it came up in your questions last time words have lots of meanings most words um have a whole bunch of meanings words that don't have a lot of different meanings are only some very specialized scientific words okay so my example of of word with multiple meanings is probably not the first one you think of all the time um the most famous example of a word with a lot of meanings is bank which already came up last time and I use star which
is another one here's a word that you probably don't use that often um but it you know it still has lots of meaning so the word Pike what are some things that the word Pike can mean fish a fish yes it's a kind of fish okay we've got one what else can a pike be yeah a spear a spear yeah for the Dungeons and Dragons crowd yeah there's a long arm right yep that's another one yeah a road right yes so Pike is used as a shorthand well a shorthand for a ter Turn Pike why it's called a Turnpike
where yeah originally you had you know this the spey looking thing um at the start of it as sort of count people okay we've got three other thing meanings for pike yeah is it also a crap like a [Music] fraternity I'll believe you I can't say I know that one um are Pikes sharp as like a needle something Sharp maybe I mean I think it's really the sort of Pike as the weapon other scratch your heads um one that I think a lot of you will have seen um in diving and swimming you can do a
pike Olympics if you see olympic diving there are Pikes anyone seen those um trust me that's a pike um okay um and we've sort of been doing um the noun uses but you know you can also use Pike as a verb right you know like once you've got your medieval weapon you can Pike somebody um and that's a usage of Pike um and you can do other ones right so uh here we go here's um um ones I got from a dictionary we got most of those there are sort of weirder usages right like coming down
the pike that's kind of a metaphorical use that comes um from the the road sense but it sort of ends up meaning the future um yeah um in Australia we also use Pike to mean um sort of chicken out of doing something um but I don't think that usage is really used in the US anyway words have lots of meanings so how can you deal with that well one way you could deal with it is to say okay words have several meanings and so we're just going to say words have several meanings and then we're
going to take instances of words in text we're going to Cluster them based on their similarity of occurrence to decide which sense of the word to regard each token as and then we're going to learn word vectors for those token clusters which are our sensors and you can do that um we did it in 2012 before word de came out um so you see here we have bank one and somewhere over here we have Bank two and here we have Jaguar one Jaguar 2 Jaguar 3 Jaguar 4 and you know this really works out great
right so Jaguar one um picks out the sense of the um kind of car right and it's close to luxury and convertible Jaguar 2 comes right close to software in Microsoft and this one's a bit of a historical one but you know it's when you were when most of you were five or whatever you might remember um Apple used to use large cats for versions of um Mac OS right so sort of Mac OS 10.3 or something like that a long time ago was called Jaguar right so it's software close to Microsoft um Jaguar 3 um okay
string keyboard solo musical um drum base that's because there's a Jaguar keyboard um and then finally um the sort of what we think of is the basic sense but turns out turns up rather Less in text corpor normally um Jaguar next to Hunter is the animal right so it's done a good job at learning the different sensors but you know that's not what's actually usually done these days and instead you know what's usually done is you do only have one vector for Jaguar and when you do that um or Pike here the
one vector you learn is a weighted a weighted average of the vectors that you would have learned for the senses um it's often referred to as a superposition because somehow um neet math people like to use physics terms um and so they call it a superposition but it's a weighted average so you're taking the relative frequency of the different senses and multiplying the vectors you would have learned if you'd had sense vectors and that's what you get as the representation as a whole
um and um you know I can make a sort of a linguistic argument as to why you might want to do that um which is you know although this model of words have senses is you know very longstanding and common I mean it's essentially the way dictionaries are built right you look up a word in the dictionary and it says sense one sense 2 sense three and you get them for things like bank or Jaguars we're talking about I mean it's sort of really a broken model right that like word meanings have a lot of nuance
they're used in a lot of different contexts they are extreme examples like Bank wherever it was where we have Finance bank and Bank of a river bank over here where it seems like the senses are this far apart but you know most words have sort of different meanings but they're not actually that far apart and trying to cut them into senses seems actually very artificial and you know there you know if you look up different dictionaries and you say how many senses does this word have pretty much everyone
will give you a different answer so the kind of situation you have is a word like like field well a field can be used for a place where you grow a crop um it can be used for sort of natural things like a a rock field or an ice field it can be used for a sporting field um there's the mathematical sense of field now all of these things sort of have something to do with each other I mean the math one's further away but the physical ones are sort sort of flat spaces um but you know the the the sense
of it being a sporting field is clearly kind of different from the sense of it being an ice field is the ice field and The Rock field different or am I just modifying they are they different senses right so really you sort of have a kind of a a uh what a math person say is sort of like some probability density distribution over things that can be meant by the meaning of a word so it sort of maybe makes sense to more use this model where you're just actually saying we have a vector that's an
average of all the contexts and we'll see more of that when we get to contextual word vectors um later on um but one more surprising result on this is um since you you have um the vector for pike overall being the sum of these different um sense vectors you know standard math would tell you that if you just have the single Vector there's no way that you can recover the individual sense vectors but um higher maath tells you um that actually these um Vector spaces are so high dimensional and sparse that you
can use ideas from sparse coding Theory to reconstruct the sense vectors out of the whole vector and if you actually want to understand this um some of the people in statistics David Dono I think is one of them um teach courses on sparse coding Theory um but um I'm not going to try and teach that but you know here's an example um from this paper the San Al where one of the ATS is tar who's now faculty in computer science here where they uh starting off with the word vector and using sparse coding um to
divide out sense vectors from one um word vector and they work pretty well right so here's one sense of tie which is piece of clothing another sense of tie which is ties in the game um this one is sort of similar to that one and I'll admit but this sense of tie here is then a tie as sort of you put on your electrical cables um then you have the musical sense of tie right at least four out of five they've done a pretty good job of getting senses out of this single um word vector by sparse coding so
sparse coding must be cool if you want to go off and learn more about it okay okay so that's everything I was going to say about words vectors and word senses is everyone good to there any questions I'll Rush ahead for the last two pieces okay so I just wanted to start to introdu in the last 15 minutes um the ideas of how we can build neural classifiers um and how we start to build in general neural network works I mean in a sense we've already built a very simple neural classifier our word DEC
model is predicting what words are likely to occur in the context of another word um and you can think of that as a classifier but let's look at a simple classifier like our named entity recognizers I mentioned before so for the named entity recognizer we want to label words with their class so we want to say these two words are a person but the same words Paris and Hilton are then locations in this second sentence so words can be ambiguous as to what their class is um and the other state is that
they're not a named entity at all they're just a word um that is some other word and this is something that's used in lots of places um as a a bit of understanding so if you've seen any of those web pages um where they've sort of you know tagged company names with a stock ticker or um there links on a Wikipedia page to a Wikipedia page or something like that right you've got named entities where commonly after finding the named entities um you're doing this second stage of entity
linking where you're then linking the named entity to some canonical form of it like a wikkipedia page but we're not going to talk about the second part of it um for the rest of the day um and so um we could say that building with our word vectors we've got this simple task where what we're going to do is we're going to look at a word in context because sometimes Paris is a name of a person sometimes it's a location and so we're going to want to look at this word in its context and say aha this is a
name of a location in this instance and so the way that we going to do it um is we're going to form a a window classifier so we're going to take a word with a couple of words of context on each side and for the words in our context window we're going to use our word vectors because we want to show they're useful for something and then we want to feed this into something that is a classifier and our classifier um it's actually going to be a really simple loc classifier we're only here going to do
location or not a location so this one here we're W to say for this um window here yes it's a location um and whereas if it had been I what I love Paris Hilton greatly um then we'd be saying no because Paris the word in the middle of the context then isn't um a location so that's sort of the idea of a classification or classifier we're making assigning some set of classes um to things right so in general for classifiers um we do supervised learning which means we have some labeled
examples our training data set so we have input items XI and for each one we've got a class Yi so I had for my ex example training examples ones like I love Paris Hilton greatly that was negative not a location and I visit Paris Every Spring that's positive that is a location where I'm actually classifying the middle word okay so inputs labels and in general we've got um labels are a set of classes so my set here is simply location not a location but I could get fancier and I could say
I've got five classes I've got location person name uh whatever other ones there are um company name drug name right I could be assigning a bunch of or other not a name a bunch of different classes but I'm going to be doing it with only two because I'm using this example on next Tuesday's lecture as well and I'm wanting to keep it simple um so that's what we're going to do and so what we're going to be using in our class um is neural classifiers and so I just wanted
to sort of um sort of just sort of go through quickly just the sort of food for thought as we go into it so for a typical um stats machine learning classifier you can build classifiers like logistic regression or softmax classifiers or other ones like support Vector machines or naive Bays or whatever else you might have seen the vast majority of these classifiers are linear classifiers meaning that they have a linear decision boundary and when we're learning these classifiers we're learning parameters here W but our the
our inputs are fixed that our inputs are represented by symbols like um or quantities so we have fixed inputs we learn parameters as weights into that are used to multiply the inputs and then we use a linear decision boundary so when we have our neural classifier we're kind of getting some more power um so first of all we're not only learning weights W for our classifier we're also learning distributed representations for our words so our words can sort of re represent our word vectors re represent
the actual words of symbols and can move them around in the space so that in terms of the original space we've got a nonlinear classifier that can represent much more complex functions um but we will then sort of use the word vectors to re-represent um those words to do a final classification so at the end of our deep Network which we're about to build we will have a linear classifier in terms of our re-represented vectors but not in terms of our original space let me try and be concrete about that
okay so here's what I'm going to use and we'll use again next Tuesday um as my um little neural network um and so I start with some words museums and Paris are amazing I first of all come up with the word embedding of those using my word vectors so now I'm got this sort of high dimensional Vector which is just a concatenation of five word vectors so you know if I have 100 dimensional word vectors this is 500 dimensional and then I'm going to put it through a neural network layer which is
simply multiplying that vector by a matrix and adding on a bias um vector and then I'm going to put it through some nonlinearity which might be for example the logistic function that we've already seen so that will give me a new representation and in particular um if the w is say 8 by 500 I'll be reducing it to a much or what yeah 8 by 500 I'll be reducing it to a much smaller Vector right so then I can do after that I can multiply my hidden representation the middle of my neural network by another
vector and that will give me a score and I'm going to put the score into the logistic um function that we saw earlier to say what's the probability this is the location so at this point um my classifier is going to be a linear classifier in terms of this internal representation that's used right at the end but it's going to be a nonlinear classifier in terms of my word vectors um okay uh great um here's one other thing this is just sort of uh uh a note for learner ahead um since you want to know this
when we start doing the next assignments I mean up until now I've presented everything as you know doing log likelihood and negative log likelihood for building our models um very soon now assignment two we're going to be starting to do things um with pytorch and when you um start working out your um losses with payto watch um what you're going to be wanting to use is cross entropy loss and so just let me quickly say what cross entropy loss is so cross entropy is from information Theory so if you have a true probability
distribution p and you're Computing a probability distribution Q your cross entropy loss is like this um so it's the log of your um model probability um the expectation of that under your um true probability distribution but there's sort of a special case whereas if you have ground truth or gold or Target data where things are labeled one zero so like for examples of um I love Paris um when warm right I'm just labeling it one for location probability one it's a location probability zero is
not a location so if you're just labeling the right class as probability one then in this summation every other term goes to zero and the only thing you're left with is what probability is my model what log probability is my model giving to the right class and so that then is um your log likelihood which we can use for um the negative log likelihood um little bit of a complication here just remember that you want to use cross entry loss in py tort when building the model okay um before we end today um here is um my obligatory
one picture of human neurons don't miss it because I'm not going to show any more of these um okay these are human neurons right human neurons um were the um inspiration for neural networks right so human neurons have a single output which comes down this axon um and then um when you have these outputs um they then feed into other neurons I guess I don't really have an example here but in general one output can feed into multiple different neurons you can see the different things hanging
into it so you know you have the output connecting to the input and sort of where you make this connection right that's the synapses that people talk about and so one neuron will normally have many many inputs where it picks things up from other neurons and they all go into the nucleus of the cell and the nucleus combines together all those inputs and kind of what happens is if there's enough positive activation from all of these um inputs it then sends signals down its output now strictly how
um neurons work is that they send spikes so the level of activation a neuron is its rate of spiking um but that immediately got turned in artificial neural networks into just a real value as to what is its level of activation um and so it does this so this was kind of the genuine inspiration of all of our neural networks right so a binary logistic regression is kind of a bit similar to a neuron right it has multiple inputs you're working out your total level of excitation where in particular you can have inputs that are
both exciting positive inputs and inputs that are um negative um which are then inhibitory inputs you combine them all together and you get an output that's your level of exit excitation and you're then sort of converting that through some nonlinearity and so this was proposed as a very simple model of human neurons now human neurons are way more complex than this um and some people like neuroscientists think we maybe should be doing a better model of actual human neurons but um in terms of what's being done in the
current neural networks eat the World Revolution everyone's forgotten about that and is just sticking with this very very simple model um which conveniently turns into linear algebra in a very simple way um so this gives us sort of like a single neuron but then precise right so this is which this s single neuron if you use the logistic function is identical to logistic regression which you've probably seen in some stats class or something but the difference is that for newal networks we don't just
have one logistic regression we have a bunch of logistic regressions at once and well that' be tricky if we had to Define what each of these logistic regressions was calculating but what we don't what we do is we just feed them into another logistic regression and so we have some eventual output that we want to be something like we want it to say you know this is or isn't a location but then what will happen is by our machine learning these intermediate logistic regressions will figure out all
by themselves something useful to do that's the magic um right so that you get this sort of self-learning prop where the model has a lot of parameters and internally um will work out useful things to do so in general we can get more Magic by having more layers in the neural network and that we will um build up functions so effectively these intermediate layers let us learn a model that re represents the input data in ways that will make it easier to classify or easier to interpret and do things with Downstream in our new
network um and it's time so I should stop there thank you